when you
when you met with the seattle seahawks
psychologist
mike gervais he told you that every time
somebody's about to face something big
two weeks before the event they have a
moment
where it's kind of like you're almost
second guessing yourself
did you have that moment privately
yourself or no yeah and so
mike gervais such a cool dude he helped
a felix bomb gardener
jump from the edge of space he was there
help him get over some mental
claustrophobia some stuff like that
and mike i knew him then he came in to
just you know
put a little sanity in this thing right
you're jumping out playing without a
parachute
and he had a couple good points he asked
me i'm a big sports guy he said luke
i've worked with a couple
big nfl teams and done this stuff how
are you going to approach this jump
is this the biggest jump of your life or
is this just another jump
he said neither one of them is wrong way
to approach it it's just a different
mindset is this the biggest thing you're
ever going to do
or is this the just another day
and i told him in that moment right then
i said mike this is the biggest jump i'm
ever gonna do
he thought for me goes okay and we
started to approach it like that
that night i went to sleep and i called
him back the next day
i called mike and i said you know what
this is just another jump
i need to treat this just like another
jump and he said that's great that's the
way he
figured i would be thinking but so mike
worked with me with that and he
said to me at some point you're gonna
have these thoughts about hey what are
you what are you doing why would you do
this you know
those kind of things he said it usually
he thought it would happen before two
weeks
um and really i didn't have that moment
until i was about halfway up on the
airplane
on game day right i'm riding up in the
plane about halfway up you have an
oxygen mask on and
you just hear yourself breathing like
darth vader right there's
you're all alone you can't talk because
everyone has the oxygen on
and i started thinking i had flashbacks
of my son and my wife and like hey why
am i doing this you know what i mean
like
yeah i think i got this i think
everything's gonna work out great but
what if it doesn't then why would i want
to do something like this
put all of this at risk i've built this
life for myself and
why would you risk that and in that
moment in the plane
my cousin andy was jumping with me he
was one of the guys wearing a camera
he was also taking the oxygen system
from me and he reaches over
and he gives me a charlie horse on my
right thigh
punches my leg points his altimeter and
goes like this like calm down
you got a second it's that non-verbal
communication that we had he's got 5 000
jumps with me
in that moment it shook it off and i
only thought about the jump from that
moment on
moving forward that was that moment in
my mind and
mike thought it would happen way before
way before i was about to jump but
but i had that that feeling for sure
that that's that's great to have
somebody like that prepare you whether
this is going to be the
biggest event of your life or it's going
to be one of the events did he explain
to you why
either matter in preparation did he
break that down or no
a little bit uh what what he he didn't
want to direct me he's very very mike is
top now i mean he's world class he
doesn't really tell you what like i
always want to answer a guy like that a
psychiatrist i want to answer correctly
right i'm looking for the right answer
like
he says hey what are you i want him to
tell me what i should be feeling
right and he's pretty good at keeping
you you know making those decisions
um and i will say that when we started
talking about the
biggest jump of my life i think that's a
different preparation you're like
this is the biggest it psychs you up you
know you have to get to a different
energy level right
super bowl you're coming up charging
yeah um or do you want to be
my personal peak performance is not at a
10. it's about a seven or
a a five and a half to a seven is where
i personally can focus you're not over
amped on the world
and all these outside forces you can
focus but you are jacked up for the
moment
so there is a difference in how you
would prepare for something like this
there's a reason why he is who he is so
i wonder you know why he
felt uh said that whether it's the
biggest or not
if it was a method for him to uh uh
alleviate some of the pressure of you
but going back to the jump so your your
uh your friend i think you said your
cousin or somebody who's got five
thousand jumps with you he
punches you gives you a charlie horse
and you're about to jump so then you
jump out
okay when you jump out the jump is what
two minutes and 39 seconds i don't know
if
it's two minutes and 30 seconds or
something like it's about
two minutes or six seconds till i hit
okay oh so you hit the net okay
so it's two minutes and six seconds when
you're hitting the net so
you're going down when you're all the
way at the top and you jumped i saw the
video
i ca i can't even tell where you're
landing it's tiny
it was so small it's uh you can see the
area you can't see the net but you see
the area you're headed so you could
start heading that direction
and then about halfway down you really
start to pick out the pieces but it's no
joke i mean when i jumped out
you couldn't make out the net you could
make out the area where the net was
you're in the right area
but you really can't see it and and
while you're going i'm assuming that
when you do this 20 000 times you kind
of have a
way of uh moving your body and
maneuvering so you kind of know how to
center yourself
how hard is that to do with all the wind
with movements everything going on
so that was the second biggest thing
right we figured out how to make the net
we knew the net would work we dropped
these dummies in there measured the
g-forces
jim churchman had dialed in we knew if i
hit the net i'm good
but the biggest thing about this is
hitting that net imagine being in a
river or out in the ocean you go out in
the ocean and you hit the tide
and it starts to slide you down the
beach a little bit right if you want to
always stay in the same spot on the
beach you have to swim forward
the tide gets stronger you have to swim
faster less you swim slower
same with the wind but the wind's coming
from all different directions
as you jump out you have to start
maneuvering your body forward sometimes
you're in this big forward movement but
that's because the wind is going
40 miles an hour so that means you have
to go 40 miles an hour forward to be
able to go straight down
so you have to manipulate that all the
way down i had some lights that helped
guide me in
but you're fighting that all the way
down right fighting the wind and
working your way in and getting closer
and closer and that took a lot of jumps
i did
i mean i have over 20 000 jumps i did
about 350 jumps getting ready for this
and i did 70 uh my wife and i deal 75
jumps in a row
opening my parachute below 1000 feet
right above the top of the net
so that's scary about itself opening
below a thousand feet so i did
75 in a row opening my parachute
directly over the center
and from a thousand feet to the net
would it be about three seconds by the
time you would fall
and nothing's gonna grab you and throw
you off for three seconds
so we did that over and over by the time
we did the real jump which was my worst
approach by the way the real deal
um ended up i did 82 times in a row by
the time we did it for real
you can't throw a piece of garbage in a
trash can 82 times in a row
82 times in a row yeah
so so you land i saw when you landed you
didn't move for about eight seconds nine
seconds and then you started kicking you
know you were all excited when you're
kicking
and then you're on the ground you give
the high five your wife gives you a hug
everybody's coming celebrating with you
how you feeling at that moment so when i
hit the net
like that's another thing that mike told
me he's like when when you land and this
is all good
take a minute take a second and just
take it in and in that moment i'm not an
emotional guy i'm not
into the touchy-feely nonsense uh i'm
more tough it out rub some dirt on it
and get going
um in that moment i put my hands over my
head like this and it was just kind of
overwhelming all that work all that
preparation and i did it
you know and it just took a second then
i started celebrating and the best thing
is that high five you see when i first
hit the net
that was my medical exam that was the
doc
i told him i'm like hey i'm either going
to be okay or it's not going to matter
you know but that was my medical
examination
i mean what's he going to do if you
don't make it right i mean it's just
okay
kind of my point but the uh i was
honestly felt this like vibrating like
feeling of the whole thing and i gotta
say i wasn't so much i liked
mike trevay as a dude like a really
great guy i didn't really
get in the beginning the value that
someone like that brings to someone like
me
um i didn't really i'm like i'm well
adjusted blah blah but
the stuff by the time up until about two
weeks prior to the jump
i could visualize myself hitting the net
making contact with the net but nothing
after that
right i couldn't see past that and about
two weeks prior
i started thinking that i could see
times like this right i was visualizing
talking to people about it and moving on
and those kind of things
help they're little steps that i didn't
think i needed
but in the end we're huge right
very interesting yeah for me i'm like
i'm not meditating i'm not whatever
and then mike says i got news for you
you are meditating you just don't know
it
you know the way i'm the way i think
about things is on the right up in the
plane i'm
dirt diving in my head or visualizing
the the jump down and the flip and i do
it three or four times on the way up
he's like every time you do that that is
meditation that is focus
i just don't sit there in a quiet room
by myself and
make um noises uh but it's all the same
and that preparation was huge to be able
to make me
feel comfortable in the moment